hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapters 25
through 27 of an Psalms monologues you
we're going to see him discussing
substance and talking about the divine
substance and you might say comparing
and contrasting it against our normal
understanding of substance now there's
two things I need to say before we
actually go into the argumentation what
is what I'm tightening of our normal
understanding of substance I'm not
talking about a modern scientific view
which to a certain degree could it be
connected with this but but the
Aristotelian view which held that there
are substances and you know substances
then have what are called accidents or
qualities and the substance you have
some sort of essence to it the qualities
are things that are accidental to it
that means that they could have them it
could not have them so for example this
cloth right here that i have this could
be in fact blue or it could be red or it
could be whatever you like it is so off
that's that's a property but i suppose
insofar as an artifact it would be part
of its essence to be soft right because
that's that's why it was created in that
way but many of the other features that
it had
are pretty contingent you know if i were
to rip it in half i would have two
substances or one substance that's been
destroyed so we can change its size we
can change its consistency to a certain
degree you know over time it's going to
wear out we can say all these things
about accidentally you might also ask
and this is the second thing well wait a
second how did Ansel learn about
Aristotle I thought they didn't know
about Aristotle's philosophy until late
in the Middle Ages with people like
Thomas Aquinas or Bonaventure isn't
handsome too early for that well they
didn't have all of Aristotle's texts but
they didn't have quite a bit of
Aristotle's ideas floating around out
there as part of the sort of heritage of
ancient thought that they're working
with specifically when it came to
substance an accident they certainly had
put in glosses and summaries on
Aristotle available to them they did
have some Aristotle's texts in part
that's not really that important here
what is important is that handsome is
going to you might say break the whole
notion of these these categories of
substance an accident wide open in the
case of the divine so let's take a look
at what he actually has to say in moto g
+ 25 he's raising a problem as he's
doing in many of these meditations so
the divine substance is self same
substantially he's just come off of a
long line of argumentation ranging from
all the way in the teens through the 20s
where he's talking about what can in
fact be said about God substantively and
that is in terms of God substance yeah
he comes up with you know this notion
that not only is is God a unity but God
is also eternally the same Godzilla I'm
just the same in time God is eternally
the same so the divine substance is self
identical it remains the same over time
now the question
that is well why can't it also be
different from itself accidentally you
know if you think about it when we talk
about say God being he's not using this
example here but he will in prosto gia
God be merciful doesn't that mean God is
changing in some way like you know going
against the strict justice that God
wanted to impose and say oh I'll give
these guys have passed doesn't that seem
like it involves some sort of change in
the divine substance and anthem will say
no it actually doesn't look at mercy
talk about a pro slow gentle do a core
console video on that the way that he
talks about this is certainly accidents
he says what would susceptibility to
certain of those things that are called
the accidents be inconsistent with
natural immutability if taking on those
accidents causes no change in the
substance now if this requires them to
think of it about well what kind of
accidents do in fact produce a change in
the substance through this from blue to
white you're changing the substance
throw it over there you're changing the
location of the substance and certainly
you're not changing it in and of itself
but you are exchanging it a bit right
pick it up and modify the shape of it
you know wrap it around the finger now
it's not a different substance but it's
a substance in a different condition God
doesn't undergo those sorts of changes
according to handsome but he says that
there is no problem with talking about
accidents that I actually don't change
the thing some of these would be
examples of relations he says the
supreme nature never yields a place in
its simplicity for accidents that bring
about change in the same way he does not
reject being sometimes described in
accordance with these accidents yet that
in no way it posed his supreme commute
ability but as essence is not subject to
any accident by which it can be
understood to be changeable so the
divining substance is not susceptible of
any accident then he says surely those
accidents that cause a change in
something
beginning or ceasing to be present in
our judged in virtue that very
effectively truly accidents of the
things that they change so we can say
some things about God in relation to
other things you know when we call God
merciful for example again discussed in
the prosto gym that would be an example
anthem says not about changing but of
the relations between God and other
things changing as well God doesn't
change in God substance now that brings
up an interesting question and then one
that Ansel thinks is very important to
think about why do we even call this a
substance and all that you know when we
think about the way substances are he
says although the substance is capable
of taking out an admixture of
differences or change from accidents is
unchangeable purity is inaccessible to
add mixture and change therefore how
will it be the case that he is the
substance at all because our experience
with substances is that they do in fact
change look at myself you know you've
seen me in multiple videos perhaps I'm
not always wearing the same thing you
know sometimes the lighting makes me
look one way sometimes it makes me look
another way some sometimes I'm not
feeling particularly well sometimes I'm
feeling on top of the world all these
things are changes that you can observe
and we do this with all sorts of
substances so why are we calling this
thing that never changes the substance
an song says in this case substance is a
term that we're using to mean essence
esencia and we've talked about in other
videos guy has supreme essence or
Supreme Being that is what he is
discussing here so that allows us he
says to he says however great the
distances between the being who is
through himself whatever he is it makes
every other being from nothing and a
beating that through another is made
from nothing to B whatever it is the
difference is everybody
as great between the supreme substance
and those that are not the same thing
not the supreme substance is so this
leads us then to chapter 27 great
discussion here and some wants to stress
to us as the very title of the chapter
indicates this substance is not going to
be included in common classifications of
substances why not because when we think
of substances that were used to in some
says we understand them to be either
universal or particular he doesn't say
that we actually have universal
substances but he does say that we have
universal a sentient being and we have
individuals particulars and those are
substances just like this piece of cloth
that I've talked about way the whole you
know we bought a whole package of these
for doing what about cleaning my glasses
yeah they're all pretty much the same
what does that mean that means that they
are individual things that share a
common universal essence cloth right or
in this case perhaps a a more particular
common essence microfiber for cleaning
glasses cloths those stuck in dr.
Ziegler's pockets would be yet more
particular wouldn't it but you notice
that what we're doing it the substances
that we are used to dealing with like
human being I'm an individual human
being I also participate in a universal
human being God isn't like that
according to answer he's neither or is
neither a universal being nor in
particular there's nothing of its genre
it can't be compared against any other
being and so the divine like he said has
exists in the highest way of all things
again if you're a little bit unclear
about what this means to exist in higher
or lower ways you want to watch the
video on degrees of being interestingly
and some does in fact
use the term exists today as opposed to
SF in that case which which is a
significant in some ways so he says that
if vine exists in the highest way of
beings that can be fittingly called
substance with the area last to own
their precisely because of the kind of
being that it is he says since he not
only most assured they exist but exists
in the highest way and the essence of
any given thing is generally called a
substance if you can really be called
anything at all there's nothing to
prevent us from call a hem substance
what we really need to highlight here is
that we're talking about a substance
that is radically different from other
substances those that were used to
dealing with and conceptualizing so if
we you know one of the common mistakes
we see often made that Angela's try and
combat is is thinking that this
substance is somehow to be measured or
assessed or reason about using exactly
the same way of thinking about things as
we do with all the other substances that
we are used to encountering and write
any thinking about in those ways